good morning Hank it's Tuesday I wanna
ask you a question do you think the
violent crime rate in the United States
has gone up or down or stayed about the
same since 1990 the answer is that it
has gone down dramatically in fact there
are about half as many violent crimes
per 1000 Americans as there were 25
years ago overall crime rates are also
down dramatically but every year since
2006 at least 60% of Americans polled
have said that they feel that crime is
going up and I am among them in fact I
wanted to make a video about why crime
is going up in the United States only to
find out you know that that it's not
okay so if you are an American this is
how likely you are to die of various
causes you see violence down there in
the bottom right corner that's all
interpersonal violence war terrorism
murder etc now because its victims are
disproportionately young violence
becomes a bigger problem if you change
this visualization to measure
disability-adjusted life years which is
like a measure of how many years of
healthy life are lost due to various
causes so it's still a relatively small
public health problem in the United
States smaller than suicide or drug
overdoses or asthma or complications
from preterm birth or traffic accidents
and also violence is shrinking faster as
a cause of death and disability in the
United States than any other major cause
except for HIV so Hank several studies
have shown that on the internet we like
to share what makes us outraged and that
incentivizes media companies even very
small ones that make videos in their
basements to find outrageous stories
because we know that you will share them
I've done this like in 2010 I made a
video about how outrageous it is that we
continue to mint pennies even though
they cost two cents apiece to make and
are never used to buy goods or services
the problem is the penny while it's an
obvious outrage it's an exceedingly
small outrage I mean the US government
could say far more money just by passing
a long-term highway funding bill which
Congress has been unable to do for the
last six years
but that isn't as narratively simpler is
easy to get outraged about so we don't
talk about it much and then there is
Martin shkreli the Bond villain esque
former hedge fund manager whose company
acquired the rights to a drug that
treats people with toxoplasmosis and
promptly raised the price from $13.50 a
pill to $750 a pill the internet boiled
with outrage until the company promised
to lower the price two months later
they've just announced that for some
customers they are going to lower that
price all the way down to 375 dollars a
pill but the outrage at this asshat
masked a much more complicated and
interest
problem like even before the price hike
the drug cost 30 times more in the US
than it did in the UK and these price
hikes aren't even particularly new or
rare longtime nerdfighters will remember
back in 2011 when Warner Chilcott raised
the price of its drug ayzik all 12
hundred percent overnight there are
dozens of similar examples and this
stuff isn't happening because of one
individual's ass hattery it's happening
because there's a huge web of problems
with pharmaceutical markets in the u.s.
point being our collective outrage may
have slightly decreased the price of one
rarely prescribed drug but it's done
nothing to address the larger issues
that affect every American who takes
medication now of course the Internet
can and does grapple with big and
complicated problems and it's also given
a voice to people who traditionally have
been discriminated against in public
discourse and also don't think there's
anything wrong with being angry anger
combined with sustained effort can lead
to real change but when we allow
ourselves to casually move from one
outrage to the next from Penny's the
Martin shkreli nothing ever really
changes well except that maybe we've
become more afraid and pessimistic like
since January of 2010 crime is down the
u.s. joblessness rate has fallen
dramatically the economy has grown and
we report being happier on average than
we were five years ago and yet every
single month since January of 2010 more
than two-thirds of Americans have felt
that the US is headed in the wrong
direction and I feel like we're
unnecessarily inundated with bad news
because we seek it out and when we find
it we share it and so we become more
afraid and pessimistic than we need to
be but then again as a nation we've
never been healthier or claimed to be
happier so maybe we're getting exactly
what we want even if we don't know it
Hank I'll see you on Friday